[російською] Зараз будемо збиратися,
вип'ємо чай і поїдемо перевіряти сітки.
[російською] Так кожного дня.
[російською] Кузьмич, киць-киць!
[російською] Все моє коріння тут.
[російською] Дідусі були рибалками,
[російською] їздили на острів на тиждень.
[російською] Ми просилися,
щоб вони взяли нас з собою.
[російською] Я працював і токарем, і кухарем,
[російською] і цеглу клав, і дахи.
[російською] Я все вмію, потроху усього.
[російською] Риболовля — це моя основна робота,
вона мені подобається.
[російською] Здебільшого ловимо оселедець,
ми рік чекаємо на нього.
[російською] Це наш заробіток.
[російською] Буває, протягом місяця,
двох місяців працюємо.
[російською] Потім оселедець пройде —
і немає цілий рік.
[російською] Після цього ловимо карася,
сазана, сома.
[російською] Тобто покладаємось на «вдачу рибалки».
[російською] Зловиш сто кілограм — слава богу,
зловиш десять — дякуй і за це богу.
[російською] Улов сьогодні не дуже,
зловив судака і рибця.
[російською] Перевірив ятір.
[російською] У яторі я зловив карасів
і маленького судачка.
[російською] Судачка відпустив, а карася забрав.
[російською] Як людина довго не може
перебувати на сонці, так і риба.
[російською] Вона десь заходить у очерет.
[російською] Там прохолодніше,
там їй зручніше.
[російською] Коли температура повітря спаде,
і з нею температура води —
[російською] буде кращий улов.
[російською] Ці два місяці — червень
і липень — з риболовлею тяжко.
[російською] Риба живе своїм життям,
[російською] і рибалка, на жаль,
не має можливості запитати,
[російською] чому, рибо, ти сьогодні ловишся,
а завтра — ні.
[російською] Вона весь час мовчить і не хоче говорити.
[російською] Навіть не пищить і не мукає.
[російською] Риболовлю потрібно любити
в будь-яку погоду.
[російською] Буває, дощить два тижні
і немає бажання з хати носа висунути.
[російською] Але треба іти і
займатися промислом.
[російською] Зажди є надія,
що наступного року буде краще.
[російською] От він заморився, сидить і думає:
«Ну все, я сьогодні останній день».
[російською] Так кожен рибалка говорить,
що ми займаємось риболовлею останній день.
[російською] Ось зараз: зловив три карасі,
спалив п'ять літрів бензина.
[російською] Почистить рибу, зварить,
нагодує родину...
[російською] Котам дати треба...
[російською] На цьому все і скінчиться.
[російською] А на завтра знову потрібно
п'ять літрів бензину.
[російською] Так він живе кожен день надією,
що завтра буде краще.
Підйом о четвертій ранку,
о пів на п'яту виходимо
і до шостої кожного дня працюємо.
Окрім днів, коли сильний вітер, а так щодня.
Наприкінці березня ми приїхали
і до кінця жовтня.
Тут люди похилого віку
працювати не зможуть.
Фізично не зможуть —
це робота для молоді.
Один стовп важить
сімсот-вісімсот кілограмів.
Кожний стовп тримає щипці
на проволоці.
Щипці — два метри,
труба — два метри. Її потрібно забити...
Набійник важить двісті кілограмів.
Ним потрібно забивати.
Це ось котел, де вони заходять.
Воно все розтягується,
два котла, двір —
це оця річ, що між стовпами натягується.
Якщо стоїть тиждень, два,
то воно заростає.
Медуза заходить і пускає слиз,
через що з'являється каламутність.
Стає брудною.
Риба це відчуває
і не хоче заходити.
Виходить, треба міняти.
Навесні я вперше вийшов у море, воно качає.
Сімдесят кілометрів від берега, ще пам'ятаю.
А ні запасного мотору, нічого не було.
Потім сподобалось, і я це полюбив.
Комусь до вподоби нічого не робити,
комусь щось інше, гуляти,
а мені подобається такий своєрідний азарт.
Рибалки ж бо азартні люди.
Чекаєш на ту рибу, щоб зловити.
Ну от, кожному своє —
у нас такий азарт і така робота.
Різна риба заходить.
Тюлька, хамса, ставрида,
барабуля, сарган, бичок.
Дивлячись, яка риба:
приїжджають з району і
забирають дешеву рибу,
або хлопці продають по селах.
Іншу рибу ми забираємо додому:
вакуумуємо, морозимо, сортуємо.
Я з дитинства мешкаю
за півкілометра від лиману.
Тому знаюся на цьому.
Ми все дитинство купалися, рибалили.
Тут усі вміють плавати.
Для мене гроші — не найголовніше.
Важливо, аби подобалась робота.
Ну що оце би я відкрив черговий магазин,
який 351-ий
за ліком в Татарбунарах.
Ну і що далі, продаєш і продаєш далі,
купив за гривню — продав за дві.
Воно ж нецікаво, а життя минає,
поки ти сидиш у магазині і
займаєшся тим, що не подобається.
Матеріальний прибуток — це одне,
але має ще й подобатися.
[російською] Комусь треба рибалити,
комусь будувати, комусь управляти.
[російською] Усім щось потрібно.
[російською] Поки що я лишаюсь, ну не знаю...
— [російською] А як він мене залишить?
— [російською] Так, на кого я його залишу?